- Ils sont venus des
quatre coins de l'Alberta,
rassemblés par un même intérêt :
les énergies renou
Pendant deux semaines,
ces étudiants apprennent comment
installer des panneaux solaires.
Plusieurs d'entre eux sont
actuellement des travailleurs
du pétrole et du gaz.
C'est le cas de Michael Chow.
Il voudrait quitter son emploi
dans le secteur du gaz naturel
pour travailler dans les
énergies renouvela
Pour lui, le boom solaire est
loin d'être abstrait.
Chaque semaine, il passe
devant cette immense centrale
construite au bord de
l'autoroute transcanadienne.
Et l'intérêt se maintient,
malgré le fait que les
compagnies pétrolières
ont recommencé à embaucher.
"De nombreux Albertains veulent
de la stabilité. Ils sont
fatigués des hauts et des bas
de l'industrie pétrolière",
explique le formateur,
Stan Hansen.
Plusieurs entreprises
peinent d'ailleurs
à embaucher assez vite.
"Les producteurs d'énergie
renouvelable recrutent dans
le même bassin de travailleurs
que les énergies fossiles",
confirme Owen O'Connor,
un natif de Fort McMurray
qui a débuté sa carrière
dans le pétrole.
En Alberta, la production
d'électricité solaire a été
multipliée par sept en seulement
deux ans et pourrait encore
grandir par un facteur de 10
d'ici 2025.
Et cette croissance est
en partie alimentée par
les compagnies pétrolières,
dont plusieurs ont promis de
devenir carboneutre d'ici 2050.
NAGWAN AL-GUNEID, présidente,
Business Renewable Centre
- Comme les opérations de
pétrole et de gaz reviennent
maintenant à pleine vitesse,
leurs émissions et leur
consommation d'électricité
augmentent aussi, qui donc
augmentera la demande pour
crédit et compensation.
- Et un pétrole plus cher
signifie en plus que les
énergies renouvelables sont
plus compétitives que jamais.
Une réalité économique
qui contribue à changer les
mentalités dans une province
qui veut de plus en plus
vendre une image de championne,
non seulétrole, maétrole, maétrs
de toutes les formes d'énergie.
Ici François Joly,
Radio-Canada, Edm